the name porsche has been synonymous
with luxury sports car design for nearly
a century
but there is another name tied to the
legendary automaker that was
deliberately erased from automotive
history
this is the story of adolf rosenberger
porsha's jewish co-founder and how the
nazis drove him out of the company he
helped create in 1930s germany
[Music]
the two people most often associated
with porsche's origin story are car
designer and company namesake ferdinand
porsche and anton piek a lawyer and
ferdinand son-in-law
adolf rosenberger was the third
co-founder
out of rosenberger was a
race car driver a very famous one in
germany
out of rosenberger drove for
mercedes-benz he got enough iron porsche
because fred and porsche designed the
race cars
rosenberger's motorsport career ended
abruptly in 1926 after a serious
accident at the berlin grand prix which
killed three spectators
he moved back to his hometown outside of
stuttgart and started investing
initially in real estate and then teamed
up with farynon porsche
and anton pierce and out of rosemaker
served as a financial backer fernando
porsche
would spend prolifically on his designs
and the porsche car design firm was
always on the verge of bankruptcy
and out of rosenberger was the man who
raised the capital from family and
friends
on january 30th 1933 the day adolf
hitler was appointed chancellor of
germany rosenberger quit his job having
grown tired of spending his own money
and raising funds from others only to
see it be burned through
but things would soon change for the
porsche firm
after turning down a job offer from of
all people soviet leader joseph stalin
porsche signed a contract in june of
1934 with the nazi government to develop
an inexpensive people's car or a
volkswagen to transport the citizens of
the reich the car porsha eventually
designed was the volkswagen beetle
in just 13 months porsche's firm went
from near bankruptcy to profitability
from the volkswagen contract and a race
car design that porsche and rosenberger
developed
company profits in 1935 neared the
equivalent of 1.5 million us dollars
today
to understand what happened next to
rosenberger it helps to explain the
concept of arionizing assets in nazi
germany
while porsche's cars were in demand the
company had a problem that many
companies in nazi germany faced the nazi
regime wanted to aryanize businesses by
removing any jewish owners
to achieve this goal of aryanization
many companies began buying out
jewish-owned assets often for less than
their actual value or through outright
theft since adolf rosenberger had a 10
stake in porsche the family had to buy
him out
the 10 stack that he has in the in in
the porsche company
is bought out at the nominal value at 3
000 price mark which was the
nominal value of his
seed capital
of the porsche company
in december 1930.
even though profits of the porsche car
design firm have greatly increased
in the years since they are no longer on
the verge of bankruptcy adolf
rosenberger ends up selling his shares
to his co-founders
far below the market value his 10 steak
is transferred to ferry porsche who is
the only son of farin and porsche and
his wife
rosenberger later said that while he did
not directly accuse porsche and piek of
anti-semitism they quote used my
membership as a jew to get rid of me
cheaply
ten days before the nuremberg race laws
were enacted in september of 1935
rosenberger was arrested by the gestapo
and charged with race defilement for
having dated a non-jewish woman
after spending almost three weeks in
prison rosenberger was transferred to a
concentration camp on september 23 1935.
he endured four days of beatings and was
then suddenly released
baron hans von weider mahlberg
rosenberger's successor at porsche had
intervened with the gestapo and lobbied
for his freedom
but neither ferdinand porsche nor anton
piek did anything to secure their
co-founders release
traynon porsche is hobnobbing
at the spanish grand prix in bilbao at
the time and even though rosenberger
through his lawyer pleads with a friend
on porsche to do something to save his
life
he doesn't do anything
rosenberger left germany and moved to
paris in november of 1935.
even after his imprisonment by the nazis
he continued to work as a foreign
representative for porsche licensing
patents in france england and the us
in june of 1938 rosenberger received a
letter that porsha was no longer able to
maintain its contract with him due to
quote higher authority
rosenberger wrote to anton piek
suggesting two ways to part amicably a
settlement worth some 240 thousand in
today's dollars which would help him
start over in america or to grant
rosenberger porsche's american patent
license
quickly and says we see no legal basis
should give you anything
and a month later the gestapo initiates
the renunciation of adolf rosenberg's
german citizenship and leads to the
united states rosenberger settled in los
angeles under a new name alan robert
after the war rosenberger wanted
restitution as a founding shareholder in
porsha with the same stake that was
acquired from him during arianization
the case went to court and piek proposed
a settlement
144 000 in today's dollars plus a car
either a luxury version of the
volkswagen beetle or a porsche 356
the settlement was accepted by
rosenberger's attorney and rosenberger
chose the beetle
but the story did not end there
there's a part of him that still wants
to be part of the porsche company
despite everything they did to him so
even after the settlement and even after
the sudden deaths of both fernando
porsche and antompire he goes back to
ferry porsche and asks if he can do
something for the porsche company in
america
however nothing came of the meeting and
in december of 1967 rosenberger died of
a heart attack in los angeles
so why is rosenberger's story not widely
known today
for one thing fairy porsche himself
played a big part in erasing the jewish
co-founder from the company's history
almost a decade after rosenberger's
death ferry published his first
autobiography titled we at porsche
in it he twisted the truth around what
happened to rosenberger as well as other
german jews who were forced to sell
their businesses and flee the nazis
ferry who was also a former ss officer
peppered his account with anti-semitic
stereotypes and claimed it was the
porsche family who had saved rosenberger
from the concentration camp the perverse
irony ends up that
a
former ss officer
ends up introducing the porsche car in
america and not
the persecuted jewish co-founder of
porsche who has immigrated to america
that is yet another incredible tragedy
of the tale of rosenberger's life
in porsha's second autobiography
published in the 1980s ferry changed his
story removing the anti-semitism from
the narrative and reducing the story of
rosenberger to just two paragraphs
but he continued to deny arianization
took place and porsha's corporate
position has also largely been quiet on
this part of the company's history
and today you have the very porsche
foundation
which
you know is sponsoring
professorship in corporate history even
though the porsche family has never
spoken about very porsche's anti-semitic
statements about ferry porsche's
voluntary application to the 2dss and
very porsche populating the porsche
company in the 1950s and 60s as ceo with
former high-ranking ss officers
so
what is happening is that
there is a
global foundation today in the name of
ferry porsche
which perversely is pretending to be
engaged within history but nothing could
be farther from the truth
it was not until 2019 when the german
public finally got to learn about adolf
rosenberger's founding role at porsche
a public television documentary
chronicled his saga as a company
co-founder the struggles with
aryanization his fight for recognition
and how he was written out of porsha's
company history
rosenberger and other stories of
aryanization are further explored in
david deyoung's new book nazi
billionaires the dark history of
germany's wealthiest dynasties i wanted
to tell this story because
[Music]
what i found so shocking
living in germany is how transparent
some of the world's most important
companies
like porsche and bmw
are about
the history of the people who founded
them or who saved them from bankruptcy
and
how they are not owning up to that part
of history i think you can learn from
history
by being transparent about the good
thing and the bad things people did
if you only celebrate people's business
successes but not show their war crimes
or
affiliations during the nazi era
you don't learn anything from history
you just wide wash it
[Music]
you